i as an audience member heard somebody
be like liar
and i just want to tell everyone that
like no one knew it was you so sometimes
i forget where i am i think i'm like
insane khloe kardashian opens up about
her personal life and her ex tristan
thompson's cheating scandal following
the comments the nba star seemingly
takes the social media with his reaction
you just have to
deal with it it is what it is chloe
doesn't mince words in her appearance
this week on the podcast not skinny but
not fat where she gets real about being
triggered by tristan's appearance in the
kardashians series premiere just so many
months have gone by and i'm watching and
i'm now
i'm now a viewer and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] that i'm listening
to look i'm just like ah
now tristan is perhaps sharing his
reaction to the headlines that followed
chloe's interview with this message
about personal growth to his instagram
story quote growth requires us to leave
something behind it can be habits
careers beliefs even people
make space for grief in the process of
growth you have to mourn your former
life to make room for a newer you we
both grow together it just makes our
family and our bond just better in
chloe's interview she also confirms
reports about a moment during the show's
premiere party which was in response to
tristan and chloe's conversation in the
first episode you know you know i want
to you know get us back together and
build our family and
hopefully be able to expand our family
one day god willing the podcast's host
amanda hirsch recalls how it all went
down while we were watching the premiere
was the first episode you're with
tristan
you bring up like the the first cheating
situation he was like yeah it's in the
past it's never
you know it's in the past never going to
happen again and then i as an audience
member heard somebody be like liar
and i just want to tell everyone that
like no one knew it was you like
everyone was quiet as chloe tells it she
was overwhelmed to say the least
so sometimes i forget where i am i think
i'm like insane so i
you know i'm sitting next to it the
twins are on one side of me
kim and pete court and try like i'm with
family and i'm like blacking out that
i'm at a real public theater i guess
and you know the whole liar thing is
from the palm springs oh we know but for
those who don't know let's watch back
the moment in question chloe famously
screamed liar
to one of tristan's friends on keeping
up with the kardashians following the
cheating scandal with jordan woods in
2019
[Music]
chloe and tristan share four-year-old
daughter true as to whether they could
reconcile in the future
it's not likely i'm focused on
work and like taking care of me my body
and soul a source told et in february
quote it would take a miracle for them
to get back together at this point but
she is committed to co-parenting which
chloe told et she learned by example
my mom and my dad were like that it took
them years but my dad would come over
once a week for family dinners and we'll
play golf with my stepdad and so we come
from a family where we believe in that
and you share children with people and
that's how it should be
[Music]